hello everyone thanks for coming for
this tutorial
I'm settled we'll start with the
tutorial
before that there are like basic
instruction everybody should follow this
one please join the chat chat room by
data land and air flow you will find all
the basic links on that yeah so yeah
okay first of all how many have you have
installed air flow on your local system
so how many of you have filled the form
that we provided nice those who haven't
fill the form please fill the form
that's the first link on the chat box
you'll need to give your name and email
ID and then we'll add you on the GCP so
that you can do the third tutorial that
we gonna do on GCP and you will also
you'll also have need to download the
JSON file which is like a credentials
which you need to access files on GCP
after that you should clone that get up
a car would have github repo and then
the installation instruction instruction
so we'll take five to ten minutes for
those who haven't installed the air flow
on the local system and if you are
facing any problem then we are here to
help you
okay there's one more thing when you
fill the form you won't be able to
instantly download the JSON file will be
adding you on the GCP my colleague will
add you guys on the GCP and then you'll
have access to download the JSON file
how many of you are installing airflow
right now
I mean you you you you need not wait for
the JSON file you can directly go and
install their flow first
yeah
one more thing our airflow when you
create the virtual environment and using
Python 3 then then it's not going to
work there is a some issues with google
dataflow so we have written there like
there is a troubleshooting here I either
you can use Python or Python 2 of Python
2.7 while creating the virtual
environment and then do the paper
install Apache airflow that will work
perfectly
those who are installing airflow is it
everything good any problem we suggest
none of the Python 3 version sometimes
it works sometimes it doesn't
so it's weird
so everybody is able to clone the github
repository right and in the repo there
is a slide also so if you if you want to
have that slide you'll have in the
repple
how many of you have installed airflow
No is it working good
okay now how many of you have wave flow
on the system overall good good enough
because of the time we should move
forward okay so here's the agenda for
this tutorial the first upper half will
be talking for next 30 minutes which
will be quite boring but again the next
45 minutes you guys will be doing the
tutorials getting to know about the GCP
getting to know about how to build a
pipeline on Google cloud platform and
some of the tutorials will be just to
get your hands on an airflow on a local
system so that's the agenda for this
okay so who we are as Amit mention me me
and Cox shall be both watts a workout
data replies and data in G new capsule
is also an airflow meter so if you have
any question a deep down question
related to air flow then you can ask
axel okay
before starting this tutorial there is a
one truth that I'm gonna share with you
guys first of all some it's one truth
not some truth data is weird and it
breaks the shops I mean I guess all of
you will agree with me sometimes
attributes and it breaks the stuff when
it breaks the stuffs it breaks the whole
pipeline and then you end up like this
there is no clue where the pipeline is
breaking and how it's going on and to
not be in this scenario we do need some
robust workflow management system and we
will be discussing some of them some of
them are like cron up seriously nobody
uses into your scenarios Guzzi Luisi and
apache airflow these are the the last
three ones are like quite used in the
industry
cron it's good for the one job but not
it doesn't handle the dependencies so
okay here's the disclaimer I'm gonna
compare all these workflow management
system of using cars I
I'm not a fan of car but yeah that's
that's what everybody suggested me to
compare it with cars so groan it's like
the oldest thing this this this slide is
from Pete who gave the pirate or talk on
Luigi in 2016 he said like in the
beginning there was a Kron we had one
job and it train it ran at 1:00 a.m. and
it was good yeah that's the scenario
when you don't have a big data or
distributed system but if you come to
the today scenario this is not the case
it's a chaos like there was no Kron I
mean you can't handle the multiple
pipeline using cron and you don't have a
one job it's 100 and then all the
pipeline depends on the dependencies of
the previous pipeline so that's that's
that's where the Kron feels securely
also Kron doesn't provide you the
statistics of job how much I'm taking
and how it's going forward so people
came with Uzis booze is like a was the
industry standard lots of people were
using Aussie a lots of industry we are
using all you see and its oldest among
all it provided the web api java api and
CLI which is like an upgrade to the cron
but on top of that it uses XML to handle
those pipelines which is not good I mean
I mean me as an engineer I sometimes
find XML quite weird and it's difficult
to maintain also X Y Z is like quite
it's it's if ask a lot of effort to
manage and since it is based on XML and
they don't have a modularity in their
whole system it's difficult to customize
also they also have a very pretty bad
web GUI to just monitor the pipeline so
that's why I like spot if I came with
Luigi Luisi I don't know how to
pronounce so I just always say Luigi it
was the first
workflow management system totally
written in Python and you can write your
dag I'll be explaining that later on
this slide you can write you a dag in a
fully pythonic way it is pretty stable
because it came from the Spotify
engineering system
engineering team and they're using
Louise in in most of your production
environment
and it has a huge community given that
Luigi depends on the external workflow
management server like cron or something
else I don't know exactly they their
webview is again like an Uzi it's not
pretty stable and it's not good to
momentum maintain and monitor the
pipeline also they don't have an inbuilt
monitoring or alerting systems so if you
are developing type of developing and
pipeline you should be focusing on the
pipeline not focusing on creating an
alerting system for this pipeline so
considering these cons up this was the
Airbnb came up with air flow it's again
it's again similar to Luisi but but more
modular and it's it's it's it's much far
better than Luigi they have a Python
code best code base and they have an
active community there it uses trigger
rules trigger rules is quite useful when
you develop pipelines you define like
okay which tasks should trigger when
based on some conditions it also have a
cool web UI where you can just check
okay every day this task how many times
is how many how much time it's taking to
complete the job they have a queues and
pools means that if you have lots and
lots of tasks running in the one
pipeline then an if system is not able
to handle or execute parallely then it
creates the pool and queues zombie
cleanup it's good thing if the pipeline
is not working and it's it's
unnecessarily eating memory then you can
have a job and it can easily clean those
pipelines easily extensible initially
airflow was built for like running on a
local system then people came up with
hooks
this is like an another way of
integrating a flow with different cloud
system and that's how it's it's easily
extensible while working on air flow for
past eight months we haven't find major
issues with air flow but one thing we
really we really
annoyed me is like no role-based access
control it means like in in your
engineering engineering team if people
if lots of people are developing
different pipelines all the pipelines
will be visible to all the engineering
members team members so that's sometimes
it's not good good while developing so
there is no role based control the other
minor resource are like deleting dag
it's just it's not straightforward means
like whenever you delete it from the web
UI it won't be deleted from the database
so you have to go back to the database
write your queries to delete the rows
and then it will come up it's so it it
will show it in the web UI other
constant to be honest I didn't find any
other annoying features to to to promote
I mean right now we will be working on
Apache airflow 1.9 in the next version
as coke shipments and me like ok they're
gonna removed they gonna ax issue access
I mean they're gonna remove this no role
access based control there will be a no
role access big access based controller
in a batch next release of Apache
airflow means that the tag that you are
creating will be visible to you only not
to others ok so when people uses these
workflow management system instead of
having this in are you you can have this
a proper I mean no no no chaos way of
doing the pipeline so yeah that's that
that's the benefit of using workflow
management system I'll be more
discussing about the air flow because we
are here for this so what is airflow
airflow is a platform I mean any
questions moving too fast I guess no
it's good the pace is good right
Luigi yeah over airflow of see our Luisi
up it's it doesn't have a it doesn't
have a I mean yeah and it's also like
they don't have a monitoring or alerting
system like in Lua airflow you have a
different operators to do a slack slack
messaging and email message email for
further alerting system so that's like a
huge benefit over the Luisi so yes what
is airflow airflow is a platform to
programmatically auto schedule and
monitor work flow when I say work flow
exits a dot it's tag which is like a
directed directed acyclic graph which is
not like there shouldn't be any loop
when you are creating tasks that's why
if you see the if you see the low figure
this one it's always going forward there
is no loop between the task
okay so we'll have a point wise point
wise explanation for what's air flow
it's an open source ETL workflow
management tool written purely in Python
it's it's very good workflow management
system it's it's glues it's like an
adhesive which which glues the or binds
your data ecosystem it means like if you
have a different data warehouses you can
easily maintain do queries do build the
pipeline for the analytical solution
using air flow it can it can handle
failures and on failures it can also
give you alerts using email or slack you
can easily monitor the performance over
the time they have a Gantt chart they
have a line chart which shows that okay
which task is taking how much time it
can easily scale we will be discussing
more on the architecture part of the f
developed by Airbnb and it it has been
inspired by Facebook status one place
less information about the data so on
but Airbnb thought like okay if we open
source into community then we'll have a
good workflow management tool since it
is it came up came out from the Airbnb
engineering teammates and they are using
air flow in a lot of their production
system it's it's it's it is a production
ready and it ships with taxi jeweler as
I mentioned internal to exceed Euler
this is like it doesn't need to accept
depends on the external system they have
a cool web UI and also powerful CLI next
we'll move to air flow web UI just give
you like however flow looks and what are
the different things that you can go
through the air flow so when you install
air flow the first look you get is this
it's pretty basic its but when you start
working like start starting running your
dad's it would be more complicated but
it still is very user friendly as you
asked about lowing it when you look at
this you and Louie UI you find it very
simple everything is just inferred
there's nothing hidden over there so
I'll show you more in detail what are
each of the things
is it feasible to everyone so the first
the first column is turning on and off
the deck so sometimes you deploy your
workflows and then you find out that
there is some bug and you need to
restart it or you need to pause it so
you can do it using this so there's an
honour of switch so if you on it it
means it's running it's lie on your
system but if you want to pause it you
just switch it off so all the
explanation here in the UI is given if
you just hover on each of these
components the next column is that it's
simply the name of the dead the third
thing is schedule shedule is where when
you want your workflow to run it's
self-explanatory and you can also use
your cron expression so if you have
already been using cron it's easy for
you so if you want to run this workflow
every five minutes you know what's the
cron expression and just slide it the
owner as in if I don't want such that of
you some of my Dex I can keep myself as
the owner and as he mentioned the role
based access control is going to be
released in the newer air flow version
so this can be enabled to your recent
tasks so this all all the circles over
here just shows how many tasks failed
how many pass how many are up for
retries last one is just when the last
deck executed diagonals is similar to
recent paths but it's more on deck level
so daggers composed of small tasks I
will explain you later
but it's about dead there are small
links over here it says if you want to
manually trigger like they're scheduling
paths unless manually triggering as well
so if you want to just for testing
purposes want to trigger some death so
you can just click over here and it
would start running and there are
different views over here for example
three view graph view that also more
detail about how your deck is performing
any questions yeah
you can use CLI as well but I think a
GUI is more useful as in it gives you
more details if you want to know how
many how much time it takes to perform
certain tasks I think you have you is
the way to go so yeah if you on both of
the those decks it would show you that
first this is running so here every time
it would show this is anybody also that
this that is dependent here right now
yes if that's off you cannot trigger
certain dance so if any dag is off for
example this is off it won't run at all
even if you try to trigger it from a
different day yeah so I was talking
about different views so the first one
is preview so this just shows tasks
around history over time so there are
different tasks in a particular day and
if you want to know what was the status
whether it passed fail so you can see it
over here it shows vanna's May 29th of
delete cluster task was run and it
successfully passed whereas the next
time when it was on it was failed so
it's just a history over time for each
particular or each individual task the
second one is graph view to visualize
your task dependencies
this is very useful like if you want to
know your task is dependent on which of
the tasks I think this is very good and
even you can like refresh it and see
when you are running the deck in the
live mode saying okay this task is
running right now this is in hold so
there are flats over here like success
running phase keep retry and queued so
that's quite useful I guess the then is
its task duration it just shows the
duration of different tasks over past
and
on y-axis it's time in seconds and on
x-axis it stated it would just show you
that your tasks started at this time and
it took some X amount of time then this
Gantt chart this is useful so this thing
is for X number of runs so you can see
last 20 25 50 events which you can see
over here but the Gantt chart shows just
for a particular run so if you want to
see how each individual tasks per for is
performing for dissident Gantt chart is
the way to go so you can see if a task
is blocking anything so here if you see
the third task is taking a longer time
as compared to other tasks so you know
you should you can try and optimize this
task so that you can minimize the
overall run duration the another one is
dag details so if you just want to see
more metadata or more information about
your neck with how many retries you want
how many tasks there are what kind of
tasks they are Dec details I am talking
a lot about dag so it's only advice able
to see what a dag is how does it look in
code so dag Anatomy this is how it would
look I know it's not clear because of
the projector but I will show you in
detail so I hope now it's more clear so
first we define some default
configurations in Python that is who is
the owner of the tasks the start date
emails how many times should it retry so
if you say you should we try X number of
times set to number of times then it
would retry if it fails it would retry
it twice you don't need to perform
anything and if it fails you can even
configure an email so it will just send
you an alert or you can if there is a
slack API slack operator as well so it
will just message you on slack if the
task fails then retried delay that is
after how many times it should
retry you don't want to eat to retry
after just two seconds maybe it has a
net Network issue and if you retry this
after two seconds it's going to fail
again so it's only sensible to retry
after one minute two minute depending
upon what your use cases then the dag
name of the dag default arguments
description schedule interval you can
even give you a cron expression over
here then there are s dag is composed of
tasks now we define each task so for
example here you are seeing a batch
operator which just runs a date command
and at the after after we define all the
tasks in a dag we set dependencies so
which which tasks should run after what
tasks so you for example here is t2 dot
set upstream t1 so first t1 would run
then t2 would run then t3 also he said
upstream t1 so even T t1 should run
first and t3 should run after that so
this would translate to something like
this in the web UI so t1 here was
printed and t2 and t3 asleep and
templated so once it runs predate the
other two tasks are running parallel so
let's move on to learning about the core
concepts of air flow the first one is I
already explained some bits
dag it's directed acyclic graph you can
define your work flow logic as a shape
of the graph and it's just the
collection of the all tasks you want to
run in a particular workflow now and
that reflects the relationship and
dependencies second main concept is
operators so workflows are composed of
operators while dag describes how to run
overflow it's the task and the task is
composed of an operator so operator
determines what actually gets done so
for example bash operator would run a
bash command in your system Python
operator would run Python an email
operator would send a particular email
slack operator would send
slack message so those are operators
they are defined as class in Python and
that three main types of operators
sensors action operators and transfer
operators so census operators are
certain type of for printers that will
keep running until a certain criteria is
met so basically if you have a system
data lake and you are waiting for files
to arrive in your s3 bucket or Google
Cloud Storage bucket then you can run a
sensor and just look into a particular
directory again and again just to see if
your file is finest arrived or not so
you have a Google Cloud storage object
sensor in air flow that checks for an
existence of a file in Google Cloud
storage the second operator is an action
operator that tells another system to
perform an action or performs an action
by itself so bash operator as I said or
email operator transfer operators are
the one that moves data from one system
to other an example would be upload to
GCS operator so if your air flow is
installed in a VM or in your local
machine if you upload it to s3 or
GCS it's like transferring your file
from some place to some other place so
it's the transfer of returns n equations
still um so task a task is a
parameterised instance of an operator so
in the previous example I showed you
this figure so here we are using a bash
operator but bash operator would simply
execute a bash command but it does not
know which command to run so there comes
the concept of task so you just need to
give values to different parameters of
an operator so here bash command is dead
so it knows that it needs to run the
date come on so this is the task so you
can have multiple tasks using the same
operator like this one is using Nate
some the tasks will be using sleep
etcetera setting dependencies so there
are three ways of setting dependencies
like
t1 the task t1 and then said downstream
tasks that is t2 t2 or them set upstream
Teva
but my favorite as I'm kind of lazy
person so I will prefer and looks more
logical wait 31 bitwise operator T 2 so
you can just chain your operator sinc T
1 because of prat T 2 T 3 T 4 and so on
a task instance so a task instance is
characterized as a combination of a deck
a task and a point in time so if I show
you here if I click here and this task
has hello one at the if this is run at
today at 1:00 p.m. the whatever status
it has so a characteristics curve that
is by the combination of a dead the name
of the Daley's leg 1 a flow tutorial a
task task is hello world or sleep world
and the point in time is the time right
now or the date when it last trend so
moving on to architecture I think that
would explain this yeah initially
initially I mentioned that flow is quite
scalable ah yeah so we'll be discussing
our three different architecture for the
airflow the upper half is like
sequential and local which runs on a
local system the lower half is like a
distributed way of running air flow when
I say distributed way of running air
flow it means like you want air flow to
processed it or not the external system
to process the data so that's how it
runs
we generally in our day-to-day job we
usually prefer local local way of
running air flow because it's we
basically called the REST API for Google
Cloud API Google Cloud engine and then
we do all the processing through Google
Cloud not through air flow so air flow
just orchestrate the pipeline on Google
Cloud yeah so let's let's move on to
sequential executors it's it's more like
a web server and our DBMS think of air
flow basically store all the job job
metadata diameter it on our DBMS it and
by default it uses SQLite but you can
also have
our DPM is like MySQL or PostgreSQL on
other web servers sequential executor is
like as name as name suggests like a one
by one execution it's good for the demo
purpose but not being used in the
production system this is what we use
local executor the only difference
between sequential and executor is the
scheduler and the sequential executor
they have a multiple cellular and
multiple sequence of letters ovo you
will have a parallel task running on the
local executor that's the only
difference
and if if I go with the distributed way
of running airflo it's it's it runs on
celery I don't have much information
about celery but it is out of the box
from airflo they support celery and it
can it can vertically scale and
horizontally or it can also only scale
it's a production great way of running
distributed way of processing data on
airflo it also supports pool and queues
I didn't mention I didn't mention the
mazes and Kuban it is these two are like
the community-driven this is not from
the out of the box from airflow and
mazes and cuban it is way of running air
flow is still in development it's not
quite matured so yeah the next is yep I
think the 30 minute of talking is quite
over yeah we'll move into the running
air flow and doing the tutorial so will
be will be having three different
tutorials one is the basic one the
second is the dynamic way of creating
tag and that third is like running a
pipeline on Google platform
are you guys done with the installation
of airflow because we now we gonna start
the airflow and just have a look on like
how other UI looks and we'll move on to
tutorial one then any problem with the
installation no good yeah so just setup
your airflow installation directory you
just export your home I think I'll
perform with you so that you can stay
together
so all of you install air flow right so
once you install air flow you need to
initialize its method database so your
tasks run history your dag history
everything is stored in a meta database
so for a sequential in the executor you
can save it in SQLite which is by
default so you don't need to perform any
more actions but if you're low using
local executors then you need to
configure my sequel or Postgres sequel
to store this meta database so first you
need to initialize your air flow
database so you just need to run air
flow and init DB once that is done there
are two components that you need to
start one is the web server
and one is the scheduler so first you
need to start your web server you can
configure the port which you want to run
for example if you are using on Bari or
something like that which also uses the
same port just change the port and in a
new tab open air flow scheduler I'm
saying new tab because this would keep
on running you can run this as a daemon
but this would keep on running on the
backend and then start a flow sheet unit
there's anyone on issues performing this
once that is done just opening up any
browser and just go to localhost 8080
this should bring you to the air flow
web UI can I everyone access to view our
yes sorry
so once you just initialize your
database just run web server and start
the scheduler
is it done
okay moving on
you need to clone the git repo I think
you guys should have the link to our
github repository if not just go to
github data apply okay and this link
basically airflow workshop by little and
that's right
was that you
[Music]
so if you get any errors in the web UI
or in the CLI saying that in example 3
import error variable JSON or something
like that don't worry it's expected
once you clone the get report just copy
the Dex folder to F your homes and index
so Dec folder is where all your
workflows would be stored so every time
the scheduler would pick that directory
and execute any Python files inside it
so should we start for the first
tutorial all good
okay so I'll go with the first tutorial
ah that's pretty basic it's it's all
using bass command but just to give you
the feel like how you can start the
airflow drag and just have a some play
around with the web UI and check what's
the code when it's running how it's
running how you can check whether it's
retrying something like that so okay
yeah so just ogle chocolate on on attack
flow dagwon airflow tutorial and then
all you need to do is to just visible to
everybody right just trigger a drag and
then it asked do you want to really run
it or not so when you trigger it you
will see that this tag is running and
when you click on this one you'll have a
graph view of three different tasks in
this stack which is like a print hello
sleep and print world is what you are
seeing is just a graph view we don't
know what's the code is so if you want
to check what's the code is you can go
here and check what's the code so as as
explained in the dagoineh Tommy you
first define the default arguments for
the dag which I mean which is pretty
self-explanatory
some of them select email failure email
retries like based on your use cases
then what you do is like define as
defined daggers and context manager and
then you define a different task which
is like this one the second and the
third what is doing is like it's just
echoing hello sleeping for 5 seconds and
then print world that's it that's what
it's doing so if you see like there is
only 3 different last brain sleep and
this is what it's rendered in air flow
graph view the good thing is like okay
let me run it again just to give you so
now this dag has run for like 3 times
and success is 3 times there is no
failure
if there is any failure or if it's
retrying then the color will be yellow
or red when you run it and go to the
graph view it takes a little time to
start sometimes and there are color
coding for all the status of the task
like you can see like which one is my in
which one is in queue which one is in
failure mode yeah no we we explicitly
defined three different tasks in a dag
so if you go into the code there is
after dag definition this is the dag
definition right there is a one task
this is then there is a second task this
and then there is a third task this in
the second tutor we'll be doing the
dynamic way of creating tasks all you
need to is to just define a line in the
CSV file and then it will read and
create a dynamic task so everyone yep
it's continuously checking is there any
change is there AG or not so it's it's
quite is there any problem with Tottori
one it's like pretty basic all good yep
there is oh okay I'll miss that one so
if you want to see what's doing in the
what sprint hello is doing you all you
need to do is to just click on that this
part and then you will see the view log
and if you go here so it's starting
attempt of one of two we define like it
should be doing the two times and if you
see
[Music]
then you are getting is that it's
missing variables so I'll explain you
more in detail about what variable is
and how we can import it forever
yeah yes so you can configure ghosting
in our five equal F zero dot CSV so it's
at 155 so if you want to remove your log
you can okay yeah the dependence is that
the way you define the task so if I
again go to the code so it doesn't
matter how you are defining the task
here
so that's how it's maintain the order so
I'll move on to tutorial 2
this is the benefit of the airflow is
like you define your workflow as a code
so when you do the coding you will have
a lot of customization options like I'll
go to the code then again the same thing
in this tutorial what we are doing is
like we we are having a one CSV file
which defines like okay which tasks
should do what right and then what it's
doing is like it's taking an input file
whenever you do whenever you are reading
any input file in airflow it should
always be an absolute path always
otherwise it won't be able to run the
read that file so we are using OS or a
celebrity to read the absolute I mean
get the absolute path of the file and
then again the same thing we are
defining the default arguments and then
defining the dag here and then while
reading
for me I just need to show you worse
takes time
sorry further delay that's what happens
when you run thousands of things at a
single time you know you should be you
should be moving
don't do the selling tax
so it's difficult to show you I don't
know why I'm not able to move Excel file
here to the other screen and
yes
it's pretty annoying
exhale ago
most of us
yep
so what we are defining here is like
since again in this tutorial we also use
we are using bass operator in this bass
operator we are taking the configuration
from a CSV file which is like okay if so
the third call third column is like
defining whether it's asleep or Eco when
if it's asleep then sleep for two second
if it's asleep against do it for three
seconds and if it's a echo then just
prints out there that's it that's a
simple way of generating a dynamic way
of doing
so yeah if you again go to the code and
check what is doing is this is if
reading the CSV file and just reading
all the three columns in two or three
different variables and just checking
whether and it's checking whether if
it's asleep or an echo if it's asleep
then use a pass operator and do the
sleep operation if it's not then do the
Eco operation and that's how we we just
define the two different tasks that's it
and then that they they are like just a
dummy task dummy task just to have a
sequential way of moving forward and
then when you go to the graph view is
just a dummy - zero and then the first
one is the sleep one because that first
is asleep and then the dummy dag again
that task sleep and then the Eco so
these are the three three things that we
define in the dag and what if what if I
do like I knew let's say that cocktail
and then do the Eco I'll save it and if
i refresh it
so here you have task equal three we
added one more file one more rows row
and then it gonna add a task echo for
year if you see that it's automatically
generating a new task while reading the
way of from the CSV so it's very good
way of doing when you have a repetitive
task or if you want to treat I mean if
you want to create your own
configuration file and then out of that
configuration file you want to grow up
your data pipeline so that's that's a
very good way of doing this thing and
that's the benefit of writing workflow
as a code so if I run it
it sits in the queue because that's the
gray one is the queued and then it wait
wait for that dummy DAC dummied I guess
was not doing anything it's just
finished and if I go here wait for like
it automatically do the things and then
here it's running this thing sleep for
two second and that's what we defined
here right sleep for two second and then
sleep for three second and then eco and
so so basically what we are trying to do
is like we are just reading it or from
Stiles and just creating a dynamic way
of dynamic dag so that's that's the
tutorial to a anything here we gonna do
that in tutorial three yes yes sometimes
you need to write your own plug-in for
that might be like that that was the
case that we were doing in one of our
project like being bigquery we need to
define whether the weather whether we
are whatever the data that we are
existing should be should have a
partition table or not so we did we did
wrote our own plugin to access the data
inside the bigquery and then check
whether there is any date column or not
and based on the date column we did the
partition so sometimes it's available
sometimes it's not then you have to
write your own plugin to meet your
expectation yeah you can see the life
think that it's running I guess it
should complete yeah it completed tasks
Eco for I'm repeating the same thing
just to get you know that okay so it's
printing the coxal here the tasks for
was the cocktail this is a part
okay the these two was like just give
you give you enough confidence on
airflow like okay how to run how to
write or tag is there any is everything
is clear about the dagger no tell me how
to write a dag
what's the default argument how to
define a dag how to write a task and
then the setting of dependencies when
you when you write a airflow code it's
quite simple when you have a billable
operator it becomes complicated when you
write your own operators or write your
own plugin to meet your expectation or
requirements and Google Cloud there was
like some of the operators were not
available so cocksure wrote some of the
operators like checking whether the file
is empty or not so these these operators
was not available so we wrote to meet
our data validation techniques some of
the techniques so far okay
[Music]
so yeah so basically what the custom
operators that we developed it's mostly
related to Google cloud platform and
Google cloud platform they they always
provide the REST API and the airflow
community already it's already build a
hook which is like a way of extending
your airflow to another platform so we
used hook so it was pretty simple to
develop your own code
so first first that's that's why
sequential executors exist so if you
have to do any kind of testing first as
if on a sequential execute on it there's
one thing at that time so that you know
to just go anything the production
environment just use sequential editor
that spiritual executors test your
pipeline over here see what is ready
the good thing is logging in f2 is quite
good so you can define your task you can
just define your blog
what do log that as well so when
something breaks it's easy for you to
just go there and check what's wrong
with the code I think using sequential
operator and it may be just spin up a
two-body basis container using air flow
and then just try it out there one
statistics if you are a Python fight for
the death and then your main cluster and
yeah
speciate question
maybe you seen them the next person okay
any more questions we have half an hour
more 25 minutes to be honest
okay so we'll move to the tour tutorial
which is running a pipeline on Google
cloud platform so I was able to access
the Google cloud platform yeah
so before going into third tutorial we
need to be familiar with some of the
advanced concept that I have Flo has
XCOM trigger rules variables prancing
and subjects so I'll go through one by
one go through them one by one first is
XCOM so I explained you how a task in
usual tasks is defined so sometimes it
is useful to extend some kind of
metadata between those tasks so imagine
file is landed on Google Cloud bucket
but you don't know where exactly that
file and or what's the file name so you
write your operator that just fetch it's
the file name and you can send it to
your other task so that is that can be
easily done by XCOM XCOM is just an
abbreviation of cross communication it's
a means of communication between two
tasks instances this is sailed in
databases apical objects so you cannot
have a massive file that you can extend
between two tasks but something small
like what a database can support which
can be I think that right now it's
somewhere in some megabytes I'm not sure
how many but it's just some megabytes
trigger rules so imagine you want to
execute your task but based on some
condition so that's where our trigger
rule exists so for example all success
all success says that or if all your
upstream tasks are successful then you
can continue running this task so
sometimes you want you have a branching
thing and you want that just one of the
tasks one of the upstream tasks pass
then you need to execute then you can
use one success for all failed all done
so they're pretty self-explanatory
next concept is variables variables is
just a key value store it's a generic
way to store any arbitrary content there
as you are getting right now is for some
variables because we have not defined
those variables that's why our flow is
company about it now variables can be
created updated deleted and exported in
do JSON file from the UI itself or
you can also do it from the CNI planting
so dancing is us and if-else condition
basically so if you see here when this
first and then banking so the planting
task would check for certain condition
if it matches something that you define
in your code that if it matches this
thing it should execute branch a if it
executes some other if it results in to
some other thing then it should execute
the below branch we use this for one of
our clients where we are using bigquery
so if we find that the data is partition
we have a different leg there go here so
we kind of operation for a partition
table subbed eggs so sub davis are
perfect for repeating patterns we can
combine all like parallel tasks task
items so task 1 task to task a task for
you know these are both the same things
just param it may try so you can combine
these whole tasks into one section and
this section one can be the object on
different deck file which you just need
to initialize with some parameter it's
like basically creating a function so
now let's start the third tutorial
before that i will give you a quick
introduction to GC p how many of you
have ever used Google cloud platform
most of him
not to you state ok so some of the
popular products are cloud storage and
bigquery which we are going to use today
cloud storage is similar to Amazon s3 or
you can compare it with HDFS B queries
data warehouse so if you are aware about
Amazon stack it's similar to redshift so
if you are downloading the PDF you can
just click the links over there to
access a GCP project or cloud storage or
bigquery from there so you can just take
a look at how it looks like
so if you click on the link at cloud
storage this is what it would show you
there are buckets and then there are
some files in those buckets like this
did ever service account we would
require this service account to interact
with Google cloud using air flow so you
can download it from here or I just
posted in the channel top dot IO so you
can download it from there as well
similarly you can check B query
so it's just basically database and then
you can have multiple tables inside it
so first before we actually see what the
tutorial 3 does we need to do some
operations first of the first is to
create a connection that is how your
airflow would interact with the GCP so
we have created a service account
through which our airflow to have
permission to use TCP in air flow though
you have need to create connections
which should be shown here yeah in your
air flow web UI just go to admin and
click on connections
so so it should show you this UI click
on create and then you need to fill this
information which is also shown in the
PDF or the slides necky if you are
downloaded from github hey all of you
downloaded the PDF or should I do it
myself over here so that you can get it
first select the connection type which
is Google cloud platform connection ID
is basically whatever we would write in
a tag file so I like calling it an air
for service account so the project ID is
PI data 2018 - air flow key file path is
the path where you have stored your JSON
file
so it should look something like this
for you
you can copy/paste this from your PDF
the Scopes is as Google API is and we
are authorizing Google cloud platform
then just click on same
next step is we need to import variables
that are necessary for the third
tutorial I explained you two variables
for variable is it's just a key value
pair and we we generally use variables
to create dynamic tags or where we can
just change the variables in the UI and
the dag could then pick up and change
whatever it is in the variable so click
on admin and then variables
so I already have variables defined but
for you you need to just click on choose
file and the path where you have cloned
your git repository just find that path
and there would be a file called
variables not Jason just import that
file and click on import variables so it
should populate the the UI with this key
and value
one once you import this or everyone
imported the variables once you import
this you can you please change the
bigquery destination data set table to
your first name and last name so
basically what I am saying is go here
edit this and instead of cups will write
your name so that you can see what do
you have created so instead of cocktail
you can have such a scene and just click
on save
so the objective for this tutorial is
like what's the process the process is
the airflow deck is waiting for a file
to be uploaded in cloud storage so there
are a couple of arrow files we are
waiting for those error of files in
cloud storage and airflow is waiting for
it and once the file arrives it would
then use a operator called GCS to
bigquery operator which would copy the
files from cloud storage and create a
bigquery table the table would be
created with the name whatever you give
over here and it would import those
files into this table so the folders
were this file will be uploaded is you
can just click here or in your PDF and
see the GCS the cloud storage again to
see where the files would be uploaded
so if you go to the code section you
will find that there are just three
operators first one is our dummy
operator called star the second one is
the CS landing sensor where I define
what area I should be looking on like
which bucket I am looking into so a
bucket is looking into a GCS work at
what GCS bucket is is using variable dot
get so the variables we have defined in
the variable section in the UI would be
called here it would get the value and
it would set the bucket here with the
proper name for object like which files
we are looking for is this yes directory
it's similar thing it is again we have
defined this as directory in the
variable section and then what we want
is all never files so how we generally
do in ETL is let's say we have thousands
of files so we first upload those files
and then we at the end of that we send a
success file saying everything has been
uploaded successfully so I am NOT
waiting here for a thousand file I am
just waiting here for a success file so
successful is again defined by Python
variable which says I am looking for
this success file in that particular GCS
directory so I will just trigger this
tag
if you click on running and click on bag
ID you would see that there are three
tasks the start is a dummy task we
should start and just complete because
it does nothing actually
then the GCS landing sensor would start
and it would wait until the file arrives
it would keep on running so you can see
it's queued now it's using sequential
operator so it's slow and now it's
running and it would run until you see
the file so you should click on logs you
just see that it's the connection has
been established and now it's refreshing
the access token and it will just then
wait for the file so sensor check
existence of this bucket and it's
checking for this file in this directly
example we have ro so it's waiting for
this file I have not uploaded that file
yet so it's still waiting so I'll do
that now
so first I'm copying all the Avro files
in that directory these steps I am just
simulating a real-world example so you
won't be doing this but as external
system would be sending a file so G your
GCS so I am just simulating that thing
so all the other files is copied but the
sensor would still be waiting for a
successful because successful has not
yet been uploaded
so now I am uploading the success file
as well
it says operation completed and you
would be able to see the success file in
the cloud storage UI as well so if you
go to bucket the bucket we are watching
is pi retire flow you would see that it
has created a directory ever oh it has
uploaded all the mo files and it has
also created successful so we would
expect airflow to now trigger the second
task so it says it has completed this so
it found that file which it was looking
for it's a success Crichton I met and
exited so the sensor basically would
always wait for certain file and once
that criteria is met it it just then
executes the next step which here is
scoping file from a cloud storage to
bigquery so I have defined the name of
the V query data table as Satta so I
should expect here a new table being
created by a fellow called Satya in this
data set I can see many of you have also
created this table so you can browse
basically any table you can see there
are five million records that have been
imported from those everyo files like
this was the one I created this was the
one which you guys created so basically
it's quite simple and you would now see
once that task completes that basically
whole pipeline has completed the find
the air flow was waiting for a file the
files arrived it moved the file to be
query it created a new table and
imported all the Avro files
the good thing with IO is you don't need
to define schema so
that's why it just imported it there's a
different version in the github repo
which uses a CSV and also uses a schema
the JSON file which you can try out we
are short on time so unfortunately I
won't be able to show you that but there
are it's already in the github repo with
proper comments so you can try it we are
not going to remove your excesses today
itself you can use it till tomorrow so
and then tomorrow night we'll remove
your access so somebody is what airflow
is you can just use workflow as a code
Python is a very friendly language and
it's very easy to use so same goes with
airflow as she what you do is just right
give the parameters the values I think
even kids studying in 10th standard can
just pass values to a variable I second
thing is it integrates is seamlessly
into Python data science stacks so if
you are if you are doing some machine
learning stuff and using Google Cloud so
Google Cloud has a product called data
proc which you can use here and air flow
has some operators over there so it can
just run your by a machine learning
model as well and store your output in
Google Cloud Storage it's easily
extensible like if you if you want to if
there's not if the functionality is
missing from air flow you can just write
your custom air for plugins and or
operators which should be easy it's a
clean management of workflow metadata
different alerting system so if the
tasks fail you can send emails or it can
send a slack message huge community and
under active development plus it has
some pro and real world projects so many
of the clients are using this VP has
been the one in u.s. that has been
actively committing to this project and
also using it in the production that's
it if you have any questions let
you
[Applause]
[Music]